it was you'd have to admit a pretty
extraordinary sequence of events a lone
gunman murders the president of the
United States and then less than 48
hours later that lone gunman is himself
murdered by another lone gunman what are
the odds of that Congress found that
yeah it was a plot it was a conspiracy
there were multiple people involved and
brought home the first alcohol that my
father made after Jed Hoover told him
that his brother had been shot was to
the CIA Des officer in Lang who was only
a mile from our house and my father said
to him did your people do this my father
was posing the same question to him was
it our people who did this to my
brothers oh it was my father's first
instinct at the agency had killed his
brother well today we decided to find
out we spoke to someone who had access
to these still hidden CIA documents
person who was deeply familiar with what
they contain we asked this person
directly did the CIA have a hand in the
murder of John F Kennedy an American
president and here's the reply we
received verbatim quote the answer is
yes I believe they were involved it's a
whole different country from what we
thought it was it's all fake it's hard
to imagine a more jarring response than
that again this is not a quote
conspiracy theorist that we spoke to not
even close this is someone with direct
knowledge of the information that once
again is being withheld from the
American public and the answer we
received was unequivocal yes the CIA was
in involved in the assassination of the
president now some people will not be
surprised to hear that they suspected it
all along but no matter how you feel
about or what you thought about the
Kennedy assassination pause to consider
what this means it means that within the
US government there are forces wholly
Beyond Democratic control these forces
are more powerful than the elected
officials that supposedly oversee them
these forces can affect election
outcomes they can even hide their
complicity in the murder of an American
president in other words they can do
pretty much anything they want they
constitute a government within a
government mocking by their very
existence the idea of
democracy by now most people believe
that the CIA probably has something to
do with the assassination of JFK in fact
if the CIA came out to date and just
admitted it none of us would be
surprised but throughout all of this no
one has ever been able to answer the
simple question why what did JFK do that
was so terrible so threatening to the
powers that be that it would push the
CIA to assassinate its own presidents
well as it turns out there were many
many things that JFK did that went
completely and utterly against the
military industrial complex and in this
three-part series we're going to expose
the three pivotal moments in JFK's
presidency that sealed his fate so that
by the end you're going to know exactly
what it takes to kill a president this
series is based on the Incredible Book
JFK and the Unspeakable by James W
Douglas a book that every American needs
to read and will link it below an hour
story starts with Eisenhower when he
gave this Infamous speech as farewell
address right before a young story ey
John F Kennedy takes office in the
councils of government we must guard
against the acquisition of unwarranted
influence whether sought or unsought by
the military industrial complex the
potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist
we must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
Democratic processes but since
Eisenhower was the old president leaving
office and there was this new exciting
President coming in no one paid
attention to Eisenhower's prophetic
speech but for John F Kennedy he would
soon realize exactly what Eisenhower
meant stay dangerous and let's get into
[Music]
it wealthy families like the Kennedy
family always have financial advisers
that help them manage their money but
why if they're so smart and Rich why
wouldn't they just manage their money
themselves it's because rich people are
humble enough to know that when it comes
to investing it's really easy to get
emotional with your money and it's
really easy to do things wrong so that's
why they'll gladly pay top dollar for
the best advisers so if rich people are
humble enough to accept that they need
advisors you probably do too if you want
to grow or preserve your wealth the
problem is fighting an adviser is tricky
a lot of them act like they have your
best interest at heart when in reality
they don't but luckily that is where
money pickle comes in when money pickle
all you got to do is explain your
situation to them in a few words then
you pick a time that works for you and
then boom they'll match you with one of
their certified financial planners or
fiduciaries for a free video call on
zoom on your video call they'll be able
to really understand your situation and
give you tailor made advice specific to
you and only you I Love Money pickle
because instead of spending hours
Googling an investing or tax planning
question and hoping that what I find is
right I can just ask an expert on demand
and they'll tell me there are a ton of
times to choose from so you're not going
to have trouble finding a time that
works no matter what time zone on your
end so click the link below and schedule
your free video call now thanks to money
pickle for being the paid sponsor of
this
[Music]
video today JFK is perhaps best known as
a young Reckless Playboy he grew up in a
rich family he had affairs in the white
house so what on Earth could have been
so threatening about this Playboy kid
that would have Justified assassinating
him well as it turns out this is only
half of the story see beneath this
Playboy facade JFK was the exact type of
person the powers that be fear the most
JFK had a very difficult childhood quote
he saw de approach repeatedly from
scarlet fever when he was 2 and 3 years
old from a secession of childhood and
teen illnesses from a chronic blood
condition in boarding school from
osteoporosis and crippling back problems
and testified by war injuries that PL
them the rest of his life from the
adrenal insufficiency of Addison's
disease to family and friends Jack
Kennedy always seemed to be sick and
dying End quotes but that's not all most
people also forget that JFK was a World
War II veteran and he didn't just work
some easy job like a cook or mechanic by
the way he was a full-blown war hero he
was a boat commander in the South
Pacific and one night a Japanese
Destroyer rammed into their small boat
destroying it leaving JFK and his crew
stranded in the water over the next few
days JFK would repeatedly put his own
life at risk to save his teammates he
swam to a nearby Island while pulling
along one of his injured teammates using
his literal bare teeth and then he swam
back out to sea to try to signal to
Friendly boats where he ended up
drifting aimlessly for hours teetering
on the verge of death until they were
eventually saved that was the reality of
JFK's life as his brother Robert Kennedy
put it at least one half of the days
that he spent on this Earth were days of
intense physical pain and it was because
of all of this intense physical pain it
was because he has seen firsthand the
horrors of war that JFK was not afraid
of death anymore he was prepared to do
everything in his power to fight for
peace even if it meant sacrificing his
life quote by smiling at his own death
he was free to resist others deaths and
so fast forward to January 20th of 1961
and JFK was inaugurated as the president
of the US we observe
today not a victory of
party but a celebration of
Freedom symbolizing an end as well as a
beginning signifying
renewal as well as change and in the
eyes of the most powerful military
economic Coalition in history this young
ambitious new president that wasn't
afraid of death POS a threats because
there's nothing more threat the
systematic evil then someone willing to
fight against it regardless of the
consequences and here for the first time
was a president who couldn't be
manipulated by threats or intimidation
he couldn't be backed into a corner by
his own generals and advisers and soon
the powers that be would realize just
[Music]
that so when the presidency JFK actually
campaigned on Military expansion as a
World War II veteran he bought into the
military industrial narrative that
America needed to build up as much arms
as possible so it could deter the Soviet
Union but once he stepped into the Oval
Office he realized something terrifying
while the US government made it seem
like nuclear war was the last thing
anyone wanted JFK quickly discovered
that behind closed doors the guys in
charge were a lot more trigger happy
remember this was a time when most
people view the Soviets as satanic
Devils than needed to be stopped at all
costs and in the eyes of the powers that
be at the time anything short of
absolute aggression towards the Soviets
was thought of as treasonous and
shockingly JFK's top military generals
actually believed that America could win
an allout nuclear war and they didn't
just believe that America could win they
actively wanted to go to war with the
Soviet Union just so they could win and
prove it and they didn't care how many
people had to die in the process in one
General's own words quote at the end of
the war if there are two Americans and
one Russian left St standing we win End
quotes while another General said that
he wanted to publicly attack the Soviet
Union from quote hell to breakfast end
quotes JFK was horrified by this
realization he thought his number one
job as president would be to ensure that
a nuclear war never happened and yet
everyone around him was buying for war
just 10 days into his presidency JFK
found out that almost any military
commander could start a nuclear war on
their own initiative they didn't need to
get the president's approval they didn't
even need to run it up the chain of
command if they believe that there was
enough Soviet military action like an
attack or even just possible reports of
an attack they could trigger nuclear
armor genon in the blink of an eye it
was Madness and it only got worse when
JFK was briefed on their game plan for
if nuclear war did break out in the
military's plan 170 Atomic and hydrogen
bombs would be dropped on the city of
Moscow alone every major Soviet Chinese
or Eastern European city would get nuked
causing hundreds of millions of deaths
to a president who wanted peace more
than anything else this was unacceptable
never had he imagined the US military
would be so willing to allow the murder
of hundreds of millions of people
including Americans just to win a war
after he was briefed on this war plan he
famously turned to one of his officials
and asked and we call ourselves the
human race JFK started to see just how
little power the president actually had
after billions of dollars in funding and
years of handing over executive power to
American generals the military had just
become too strong and influential so
strong that by the time JFK stepped into
office the military IND industrial
complex already had big plans for
him in 1959 Fidel Cash become the
president of Cuba which meant that Cuba
had just Fallen under communism standing
just 90 Mi off the coast of Florida Cuba
was now the perfect base for the Soviet
Union to launch a surprise attack from
so by the time JFK became president just
2 years later the CIA was Neck Deep
trying to get rid of Castro and nothing
was off the table the CIA had tried to
assassinate Castro hundreds of times
they put poison in his cigars paid C
gangsters to try to kill him and even
tried to hide explosives in a seashell
in an area where he like to dive and
with every fail attempt the CIA just got
more and more desperate and that's where
JFK came in the CIA needed to convince
the new president to authorize military
action against Cuba because in their
eyes every day that passes where they
don't strike first is another day that
America could get annihilated from Cuba
but that was easier said than done you
see the CIA knew that the president
would never authorize anything as
drastic as an invasion or an open attack
by the US military it went directly
against his plans for peace and
deescalation but that didn't mean the
CIA couldn't Force his hand if they
could launch a us-based attack on Cuba
even if it didn't involve Americans
directly JFK would have no choice but to
support it and send in reinforcements
lest the attack failed yes if the CIA
could get JFK to agree to an attack led
by Cubans but backed by America and that
attack went horribly wrong he would be
forced to send in US troops as one of
the youngest presidents in history there
was no way he was going to risk such a
public failure like that just a few
months into his presidency just imagine
the news cowardly inexperienced Kennedy
drops the ball against Soviets it would
never happen JFK would be forced to play
along and so the CIA put their plan into
motion before JFK was inaugurated he had
been briefed on a plan by the CIA to
train Cuban Exiles to invade Cuba to
take back their Homeland and right from
the start JFK made it clear that the
Cuban Exiles would have zero US military
support during their invasion they would
be doing it all on their own little did
he know that the ca knew this Invasion
would fail and that the CIA was betting
on him to send in troops anyways once
the invasion did fail to save face and
so on April 17th 1961 Less Than 3 months
into JFK's presidency 1,400 Cuban Exiles
touched down on the beaches of Cuba with
the intention of taking back Cuba from
Castro and as expected over the next 24
hours they proceeded to get decimated by
the Cuban military they were being
attacked from all sides and desperately
needed air supports and that's where JFK
came in with more than a thousand Cubans
at risk of being killed and America on
the verge of a major strategic failure
the CIA called on the president to ask
for help Mr President if you don't
authorize Military Support thousands of
people will die and America would look
like a fool we be the laughing stock of
the world too scared and cowardly to
defend ourselves on an island less than
100 miles away is that the kind of
picture of America you want to paint for
our enemies JFK was backed into a corner
but the CIA had underestimated him
because JFK did not budge a single inch
when he said he didn't want any
Americans getting involved he meant it
and so with no US military supports
within 2 days more than 1,100 Exiles had
been killed or captured it was a
complete and utter failure only after
the invasion failed the JFK realized
that he had been drawn into a CIA trap
the CIA and US military quote couldn't
believe that a new president like me
wouldn't p panic and try to save his own
face JFK told one of his AIDS well they
had me figured all wrong it was in that
moment that JFK fully realized just what
kind of a beast he was up against quote
in effect President Kennedy was a target
of a CIA covert operation that collapsed
when The Invasion collapsed end quote
and that JFK quote bitterly disappointed
the CIA and the military by his decision
to accept defeat at the Bay of Pigs
rather than escalate the battle End
quotes the military industrial complex
was pissed but so was JFK
[Music]
when the CIA first came to JFK with the
idea of the Bay of Pigs invasion it was
obvious he was hesitant he had only been
president for a few months and he
inherited the plan from Eisenhower it
felt too soon too rush too drastic a
eventually JFK went ahead with it under
the strict conditions that no Americans
be involved but as it turns out even if
JFK had said no to the whole Bay of Pi's
operation right then and there the CIA
already had plans to bypass his decision
and do it anyways take a listen quote
when the four anti-castro Brigade
leaders told their story to writer hes
Johnson they reviewed how the agency was
prepared to circumvent a presidential
veto the Cuban's Chief CIA military
adviser whom they only knew as Frank
told them what to do if he secretly
informed them that the entire project
have been blocked by the administration
quote if this happens you come here and
make some kind of show as if you were
putting us the advisers in prison and
you go ahead with the program as we have
talked about it and we will give you the
whole plan even if we are your prisoners
end quote so basically the head CIA guy
in charge of the Cuban Exiles told the
Exiles that if JFK said no to this
operation that they were to Stage a
Revolt pretend to put the CIA guys in
prison and then go on with the invasion
of Cuba as planned when Robert Kennedy
JFK's brother heard about this plan he
called it quote virtually Tre virtually
treason virtually treason virtually
treason virtually treason when all the
dust settled it marked a turning point
for JFK's time as presidents JFK
realized that he could never negotiate
reason or even trust the CIA not when
they were willing to lie trap or even
bypass him without a second thoughts
quote the Bay of Pigs awakened President
Kennedy to internal forces he feared he
might never control end quot JFK
realized that if he wanted a chance at
peace he would have to wage a different
kind of war against the very people in
his own own government as the dust
settled JFK turned to one of his highest
officials in his administration and said
that he wanted to blender the CIA in a
th000 pieces and Scatter it to the
winds and he meant it while the Baya P
was still going on JFK told his
presidential adviser Mr arthus Slinger
Jr that quote it's a hell of a way to
learn things but I have learned one
thing from this business that is that we
will have to deal with CIA no one has
dealt with
CIA and so from from that point on JFK
started splintering the CIA and he first
started by going after the Mastermind
behind the whole Bay of pix Fiasco the
infamous CIA director Mr Alan
[Music]
dulis JFK started splintering the CIA by
asking the masterminds behind the Bay of
Invasion to resign which just so
happened to be the three highest ranking
officers in the CIA director Alan Dillis
deputy director Richard Bissell Junior
and deputy director General Charles
Cabell after firing the three most
powerful men in the CIA JFK then started
cutting the cia's budget hoping to reach
a 20% reduction by 1966 and from then on
instead of relying on the CIA for advice
on foreign policy he made the military
joint chis of Staff his main advisers
because he foolishly believed that the
military would be easier to control than
the CIA the CIA has spent the last few
decades operating with impunity and now
this young naive president thought that
he was going to ring them in nonsense no
one was more salty about this than the
CIA director that he fired Mr Alan
dullis Alan dullis was the most
notorious CIA director in history he was
the guy that brought down Muhammed mosc
in Iran he brought down salvator aende
in Chile and he ran the insane MK Ultra
mind control projects that illegally
experimented on thousands of Americans
in the 50s you can watch our private
documentary on that by clicking the card
on in the top right corner all these
accolades that Mr doas had built up was
all being strpped away from him by
Little John F Kennedy so if it wasn't
cleared then it was clear as day now the
cia's number one enemy was no longer
some foreign communist it was no longer
some foreign terrorists no the cia's
number one enemy was now the
commander-in-chief President John F
Kennedy after Kennedy's assassination
Alan douis would ironically be appointed
to the Warren Commission the commission
that was in charge of investigating
JFK's death so in effect Alan Dillis was
helping lead an investigation into
himself and guess what conclusion he
came to in that investigation years
later when Alan Dillis was old and
retired he had a Ghost Rider come over
to his Mansion to collaborate on a piece
defending the cia's role in the Bay of
Pigs invasion quote in one discussion
they had about President Kennedy dillas
stunned the Ghost Rider with an Abrupt
comment that little Kennedy dillas said
he thought he was a God he thought he
was a God he thought he was a
god
even though JFK managed to cut down some
of the cia's power he quickly realized
that the CIA wasn't the only problem
even though the CIA had been the one to
plan the Baya pix Invasion it was the US
military Chiefs who signed off on it and
it was them who pushed JFK to let the US
military intervene so if it was both the
CIA and the military that were at odds
with him JFK had a much bigger problem
on his hands than he expected it was a
summer of 1962 a year after the Baya
piix Invasion ended in disaster one of
JFK's friends asked him what he thought
of a bestselling novel at the time about
a fictional military Takeover in the
United States JFK read the entire book
that night the very next day he
discussed the possibility of such a
military coup in America to his friends
it's possible he said it could happen in
this country but the conditions would
have to be just right if for example the
country had a young president and he had
a Bay of Pigs there would be a certain
uneasiness maybe the military would do a
little criticizing behind his back but
this would be written off as the usual
military dissatisfaction with civilian
control then if there were another Bay
of Pigs the reaction of the country
would be is he too young and
inexperienced the military would almost
feel that it was their patriotic
obligation to stand ready to preserve
the Integrity of the nation and only God
knows just what segment of democracy
they would be defending if they
overthrew the elected established M
pausing for a moment he went on then if
there were a third Bay of Pigs it could
happen but it won't happen on my
watch JFK had just had his first Bay of
Pigs but little did he know that his
second one was just around the corner
and so my fellow
Americans ask not what your country can
do for you ask what you can do for your
country all this will not be finished in
the first 100
days nor will it be finished in the
first 1,000 days but let us
begin